must dive movie yeah oh here we go here
is oh here is what what bro what is it
yeah I know but that was for other
people so come on in will where you been
shooting your eyes are kind of dead this
morning
well ah that's annoying oh my god
can you not bring a an office size
cooler jug of water get a bigger chair
these chairs constrain my hips
I'll do the way that I'm not comfortable
with well I can't I can't bring in a
bigger chair for you just because
getting bigger chairs for Boethius well
Brendan's a big guy he's got a big
athletic high bubble but he does how he
that's how he [ __ ] trains that's how
he beat the [ __ ] out of people yeah he's
got her years and years I got a high
athletic bubble but yeah but it's little
and cute little cute bubble but Brian
Callens ass
that's the but the fits in a red chair
no sass what how long has it show been
going this way it's so cool to be into
things every now and then you don't do
any job
[Applause]
what dude reboot Punk'd
hey hey hey look Will's got a [ __ ]
three gallon jug no you know I'm just
here to hang out don't mind me
do you interview guys when you say that
yeah what's up man see okay good but you
gotta admit we [ __ ] got you right
Chris uh yeah I didn't glasses off I
didn't know you were coming all right
but I didn't know you're coming so yeah
let's regroup here yeah so but pretty
good you gotta admit right sure it's
pretty good I don't mean to like get in
on your no it's okay we were talking
about a [ __ ] thing little bit of
escapism is dude I don't like to [ __ ]
talk about that ship a bride and drink
his [ __ ] boat yeah because he's us
cuz he's a sweet tart tart mask that's
not no because I have survived raw Barry
and Doc did I talk to will like will
that whole thing down you guys trying to
fight it well he by I know he was joking
around with you both have yeah no no no
come in with a cowboy hat no it's not a
nice hat
just are you rolling yes I'm this
[ __ ] guy comes in with a hat
sunglasses and a gallon of water yeah
these are my blunt stones these are my
blood stones okay well looks like we
just started a new ad campaign for blood
sauce haha these are my blood stones
these are my blood stones you got
chocolate in my blood stones you got
peanut butter in my blunder take it easy
guys good new Jesus Christ
well Sasso is taking over for Brendan
Schaub today don't just throw things I'm
not this time yes [ __ ] table minutes
don't bring real furniture has been on
the air since iPods exist do you know
that iPods don't exist anymore yeah I do
oh you don't yeah I do no don't do the
base thing well I'm not doing the Bears
thing this is my natural resting voice I
don't know about that I'll tell you
something you um [ __ ] this doesn't
brother that's a water cooler sighs yeah
Tanner Brian okay ha ha everybody knows
we it's so annoying we that I drink a
lot of water what do you want today why
did you know what I want what do you
want
here's first question yes first question
oh [ __ ] do you think you are wearing a
hat like that that's actually a really
good question Brian yeah and I'd like to
just listen I want to talk directly to
your listeners okay they know that every
time you want to talk about me being in
Tempe this is tomorrow Friday Saturday
ruff oh sure I'll tell them Tempe improv
Bryan Callen you said well I want to
tell them God Bryan Callen will be at
the Tempe improv it has 54 seats no it
has a lot more than that's a huge room
I've never been there
well if you want to come and open for me
and be my [ __ ] opener and get water
and towels you can that'd be great but
uh you know what I'm not a stand-up
comedian Bryan I'm a serious actor and
I'm a serious will [ __ ] sasso ladies
and gentlemen Seth will sasso Nate Nate
Nate Schumer
knate knate summer and I are taught heat
because you were late
Nate amen no take that get that get that
sign off bro get that sign up what's up
man all right dude take hey take it easy
bro
ah what are you doing all right secret
handshake it's not I've never agreed to
this
bro what are you what are you doing man
I don't Will Sasso Nate I want to thank
you for making an appearance on the
fighter and kid well in the man No all
right take it hey I'm just here to
co-host the show sitting in for
Brennan's job big ready shouts got the
big brown breakdown check it out Bratz
brands got a new no don't talk about
well he's got a new line of socks no he
died brown socks no I don't think he did
brown socks check out your big brown
socks big brown socks calm the brown Pig
and their socks so if you have over a
size 17 foot you're gonna want big
Browns wick away moisture technology all
right we got big shitty stinky sweaty
feet like me now Brian you know I wear a
size 22 and I will put it through your
face so hump keep at me about being late
no one hang a sign on the door I'm
supposed to walk through ever again I do
take that as an offense okay then listen
up
big brown Sascha only way to get your
big brown breakdown not an advertiser
Brown sounds [ __ ] socks it listen up
maybe you would try to bring that foot
yeah but you didn't know Brown has been
87 shades Brown listen up we got 150 you
reach my face with your foot cuz I move
so quickly and I can measure distance
and you and kick and you to overstep and
then your [ __ ] face with you and I
would go back yeah yeah I go boop boop
boop
I understand combinations boop boop yes
whack and you go meet me and [ __ ] your
pants how did your pants enough to run
away hey how did that guy what was that
guy the Crocodile Hunter rock it out
Dundee you know the guy the Bieber
passed away the Okinawans different now
how did he die
I'm already annoyed with this giant
[ __ ] water bottle of yours man you
drink too much water broke you just do
if you drink too much water you can't
excuse me drink enough water
take it how did to see one died somebody
he had he got he tried to pet a stingray
from what I understand yeah and it's
shot it's it's barb into his heart and
God bless the man he passed away
how BIG's a stingray I don't know will
is probably a very big stingray probably
had a wingspan of about six to eight
feet okay now we're gonna go ahead and
say we're gonna go ahead and put the
over-under at under when we say that my
foot is the size of a stingray it's
probably a little smaller right it's a
little smaller but not by much I don't
believe in getting pedicures okay so if
you come close to me and I'm just
wagging my foot around and I just send a
gnarled yellow toenail don't into your
chest I cut you don't do I cut your nail
leave out no I'm not touching you get
your finger this is on our podcast
getting there the [ __ ] bro I'm warning
you I can't be on the telephone no I can
push I can be pushed just so far Brian I
can be pushed that's not my voice oh
test your log only be pushed so far see
me still show oh there he is
what are you drunk all right man forty
minutes what's up brother you got the
jug of water as usual hey look hey look
are you drunk or what man are you are
you high bro do whatever you want now
we're gonna pause because I'm gonna go
piss cause I gotta see you man I'm gonna
stand up that's an awkward kiss and hug
and gentlemen the white Samoan Will
Sasso the white Samoan is a shame like
polar bear the white polar bear are you
really taking a little pause yeah why
what do you want to do I'll do whatever
you want
all right [ __ ] all right I'm not big
telling you I'm just big time keep it
going
okay I'm gonna tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]